in the sense of this if okay
before the rules of women having the
right to be equal it wasn't like men
were like oh you're just a slave in my
room no we said there's certain things
that are for women and certain things
are for men benefits and disadvantages
women didn't have to fight in wars right
exactly they didn't have to do hard jobs
didn't have to climb chimneys and do
nothing they like okay so
you're locked in the house okay your guy
is locked in a factory
he's locked in a pit like they say oh
you know it's like oh they locked us up
the guy was he didn't have minimum wage
he didn't have like he didn't have no
safety measures he was working trying to
pay for his family like we way we how we
fantasize how back in the day was like
we lived there like we just came from
the revolution it's like no none of us
lived there so when you say society was
this way it's like no no that's how this
is how it is now this is how we want it
to be
yeah
there's too many feminists and too many
male feminists